hello everybody I was I'm very happy to
be here today and I was very
disappointed not to be here for the
first two lectures on Tuesday I was
teaching and on Wednesday in testimony
to event saturation at Yale I was
hosting a different lecture but I'm
delighted to be here today I have known
Rogers since he first came to Yale in
1980 I believe at which time he was a
starting assistant professor and I was a
truly obnoxious graduate student who
wouldn't listen to anyone and was
convinced I knew everything and he
nonetheless gave me large amounts of
very good advice which I think I'd have
done better if I taken more of it sooner
in particular he kept telling me was
fine for me to think everybody in the
world is wrong and and point that out in
four point harmony but at this time
would come when I would actually have to
make some arguments of my own and he he
he was right about that and he also
exhibited the trait that is the one of
the many impressive things about him
which was that he always thought his job
was not to tell you what to do or to
make you be a duckling but to get to do
his best to help other people make the
arguments they want to make as well as
possible and so this is one of my
enduring disagreements with him he
thinks that he's a lucky and liberal but
in fact he's an Aristotelian because he
understands that people are plastic and
pliable and need to develop to become
the the selves that they can be and not
only does he believe that he acts on it
and and anyone who's had him on a
dissertation committee will know that
that is how he he works with graduate
students it's also how he works with
with with undergraduates and with
colleagues and so he's he's a truly
terrific I've known him as a as a
professor and then as a colleague in and
I can I can tell you that he's one of
the people that causes you to change
you're right as opposed to just hit you
over the head with what he thinks or say
things that you'll end up ignoring so he
really adds value to the people that he
works with and I think that that's that
is his central trait so these castle
lectures that he's delivering are right
on the subject that informs them the
mission of the castle lectures which is
is to speak to issues that are of great
ethical importance in a complex modern
society and I'm sure you heard it
earlier lectures about the dedication of
the castle lecture series so I won't
repeat that the general title of these
lectures that's not who we are populism
and stories of people hood is a subject
I know that has been dear to his heart
for considerable time and has informed
quite a lot of his recent writings and
today he's going to be giving electric
cold who are we Americans now he's going
to be talking about the story of people
hood being pressed by President Trump
and canvassing some alternatives that
might more profitably be impressed than
that
so Rogers welcome back
[Applause]
thank you very much in I have benefited
enormous ly from my discussions with
many colleagues here over the years and
none more so than Ian even though they
have often been matters of disagreement
that have changed my own thinking and
now I expect I'll give a lecture with
which he'll disagree today so my title
for this lecture let's see is who are we
Americans now and it references who are
we the challenges to America's national
identity the last book by the late
highly accomplished but highly
controversial political scientist Samuel
P Huntington in 2017 Carlos lazada book
critic for The Washington Post wrote
that Huntington was a prophet for our
time because his vision especially is
expressed in this book is partially
reflected in Donald Trump's message and
appeal even though lazada said
Huntington might be apprehensive about
Trump's personal traits in who are we
Huntington not only departed from he
subtly mocked his own earlier view that
American identity rests strictly on
embrace of the liberal democratic
principles of the American creed he
cited with approval one of his critics
Roger Smith who said this view is at
best a half-truth the other half
Huntington now contended was that
American identity has a cultural core an
Anglo Protestant culture that he
portrayed as threatened today by Mexican
immigration and militant Islam the
similarities of Huntington's arguments
to statements of Donald Trump who began
his presidential campaign by warning
against the dangers of Mexican
immigration and later called for a ban
on Islamic immigrants are clear those
two positions define Trump as an
anti-immigrant populist and
to many other right-wing populist
leaders around the world today for those
of us who believe that America has
benefited enormously from immigration
including modern Mexican and Muslim
immigrants and you also believe that the
US has deeply entrenched traditions of
racial and religious as well as gender
bigotry that must always be firmly
combated these positions and others that
President Trump has taken are anathema
yet it is undeniable that they have
helped Trump rise to heights few thought
possible
although most leaders of both parties
not only opposed but openly ridiculed
Trump early in 2016 he defied
expectations in part because he told a
story of American people hood that
resonated deeply with enough ordinary
Americans to enable him to win the
Republican nomination easily and the
Electoral College vote narrowly in his
inaugural address President Trump gave
his story a name similar to the one
adopted in the winning 2014 manifesto of
India's Hindu nationalist baiji BJP that
I discussed yesterday Trump promised
from this day forward a new vision will
govern our land from this day forward
it's going to be only America first
America first now I've been arguing that
in many political contexts today it's
both possible and and necessary to
combat narrow repressive stories of
people hood with more inclusive
egalitarian ones is it necessary to
advance such stories in America today
and if so can better stories be found my
answer unsurprisingly is yes to both to
make that case I will first consider
president Trump's America first vision
more fully and then turn to some
alternative accounts of American people
hood that might constructively compete
with it I will explain why I regard one
of these stories portraying America is
devoted to carrying forth the
declaration of independence project of
securing rights for all people of all
colors everywhere as on balance the best
American story
my goal however is not
to persuade everyone to accept it
instead my hope is to encourage others
to put forth a variety of distinct
though overlapping good stories of
American people hood enriching
democratic discussions that should
ultimately decide who we are as
Americans now president Trump's
inaugural address fit perfectly with
modern scholarships minimalist
definition of populism as a quote
ideology that posits a struggle between
the will of the common people and a
conspiring elite Trump narrated
America's past as one in which quote a
small group in our nation's capital has
reaped the rewards of government while
the people have borne the cost too many
of our citizens have experienced
American carnage he said but he
announced January 20th 2017 will be
remembered as the day the people became
the rulers of this nation again he
promised a future in which every
decision on trade on taxes on
immigration on Foreign Affairs will be
made to benefit American workers and
American families new initiatives would
bring back our jobs bring back our
borders bring back our wealth with quote
new roads and highways and bridges and
airports and tunnels and railways
getting people off welfare and back to
work and make America great again the
president said his America first vision
rested on the conviction that quote a
nation exists to serve its citizens it
is the right of all nations to put their
own nation first he maintained that
Americans do not seek to impose our way
of life on anyone but rather to let it
shine as an example for everyone to
follow he also contended that his vision
encompasses all the citizens of America
Americans he said form one nation
sharing one heart one home and one
glorious destiny with no room for
prejudice but rather an awareness that
whether we are black or brown or white
we all bleed the same red blood of
patriots then in a manner that many
proponents of diversity found ominous
Trump asserted the bedrock of our
politics
we'll be a total allegiance to the
United States of America and through our
loyalty to our country we will
rediscover our loyalty to each other in
terms of the three criteria for good
stories of people out lined yesterday
the three r's of resonance respect and
reticulation trumps america first
narrative certainly resonated with
economic cultural and political concerns
and deeply valued identities of many
millions of Americans he also sought to
convey respect for all American citizens
as well as other nations his vision of
America appeared however to leave little
of any room for what I called
reticulation for the greatest feasible
recognition and accommodation of the
many diverse communities cultures and
ways of life that comprise modern
America his rhetoric raised reasonable
worries that in a pluralistic society
demands for total Allegiance might lead
to totalitarian consequences before and
since his inauguration Trump's tweet
speeches and most importantly his
policies and provided abundant evidence
of his hostility to many forms of
diversity
prior to his pursuit of the presidency
Trump repeated Trump's repeated
challenges to Barack Obama's citizenship
already suggested that he found
something unamerican about an
african-american president during the
campaign he continued an american-born
judge of Mexican descent could not apply
the law fairly and he disparaged the
lives of black and brown Americans
grossly overstating criminal statistics
for blacks and immigrants and a May 2016
rally Trump reportedly made the
revealing remark the only important
thing is the unification of the people
because the other people don't mean
anything whatever the truth about
Trump's personal racial views may be
moreover his promises to make America
great again
clearly spoke most powerfully to those
who looked back favorably on an older
predominantly white Christian male
governed nation an
of his electoral support overwhelmingly
concur that Americans who believe the US
should be a predominantly European
descended Christian nation saw Trump as
their candidate John sides riding as
part of the democracy fund voter study
group found that in the summer of 2016
30 % of Trump supporters thought it was
important for Americans to be of
European ancestry 72% thought Americans
should be born in the United States and
63% thought being Christian was fairly
are very important to being American
these figures were all much higher than
those for any other candidate they led
Lind avrech to conclude mr. Trump's
focus on ethnicity religion and American
identity was the catalyst that United a
relatively small set of Republican
primary voters behind him and helped him
defy expectations and become the GOP
nominee in office Trump's comments
suggesting that there were good people
among the white supremacist protesters
at Charlottesville derogating African
countries and Haitian immigrants
criticizing African American athletes
and celebrities protesting against
police violence against people of color
and many more have continued to appeal
to those with strong senses of white
identity while alienating other
Americans
moreover trumpet his appointees have
done much to advance the social policy
preferences of these Trump voters though
economic initiatives to build roads
highways bridges airports tunnels and
railways have not happened under
attorney general Jefferson Sessions the
Justice Department Civil Rights Division
is pursuing lawsuits against
universities suspected of over
emphasizing race and their affirmative
action admissions policies the Justice
Department and the Department of Housing
and Urban Development headed by Ben
Carson have stopped filing disparate
impact suits to advance the Fair Housing
Act school of fighting racial
discrimination in housing the Trump
administration also quietly ended a
federal grant to a group working to
oppose white nationalist extremist
organizations it created a commission to
investigate vote fraud led by one of the
nation's most extreme proponents of
anti-immigrant and voter restriction
laws Kansas secretary of state Kris
Kobach the Commission faltered but it
administration and Republican support
for voter initiatives that are likely to
suppress non-white voting continued
sessions and former Trump advisor Steve
Bannon have each praised the race-based
National Origins quota immigration
system of the 1920s though there are no
plans to revive it the administration is
adding a citizenship question to the
census that may aid deportations and it
favors immigration legislation that
would not only replace family
unification priorities that have foster
demographic diversity with preferences
for high-skilled immigrants it would
also reduce overall legal immigration in
light of all these policies it is
difficult to see Trump's America first
program as genuinely respectful toward
and responsive to all Americans or even
as clearly committed to democracy human
rights and the rule of law Americans
therefore have a civic and moral duty I
believe to explore whether there are
better stories of American people hood
that can check these features of Trump's
America first vision while also
responding to the legitimate concerns to
which he has spoken powerfully three
distinguishable narratives appear
particularly promising these are first
American politics as a democratic
project the view of John Dewey and
others second America as a
constitutional endeavor seeking a more
perfect union without a facing diversity
the e pluribus unum story told best by
Barack Obama and third America defined
by the declaration of independence
project of extending rights to all the
vision articulated most memorably by
Abraham Lincoln
so first democratic stories as is well
known many of the framers of the
American Constitution including James
Madison himself harbored deep fears
about the dangers of democracies and
insisted they were creating republics
with governance by elected
representatives but not direct popular
rule there embrace a popular
self-governance proved however difficult
to cabin with Fitz starts and some
important reversals the ensuing history
of the United States displays wider and
deeper embrace
of democracy these include the renaming
of the Party of Jefferson as the
Democrats in the age of Jackson the
expansion of the franchise to all white
men then all men that all male and
female citizens over 21 and eventually
eighteen year olds as well and the
adoption of direct election of judges in
many states in the 19th century and of
US senators via the 17th amendment as
well as the democratization of candidate
selection processes through the spread
of primaries in the 20th century these
historic developments suggest that
stories of America as a democratic
project have a serious claim to be the
stories that have done the most to
advance inclusive egalitarian visions of
American people hood in the past and
they may be the best to do so today
commitments to democracy in fact suggest
an important alternative to the strategy
of developing good stories of people
hood that I'm advocating here perhaps
egalitarian inclusion is most attainable
through promoting broad of often
grassroots Democratic engagement and
self-governance without advancing any
particular account of who the people are
perhaps organizing around resistance to
specific forms of oppression
exploitation and domination in the name
of achieving more democratic and
egalitarian conditions is both
sufficient and safer America's greatest
Democratic theorist John Dewey often
argued in this Fame more recently in
calling for a left populism the European
political theorist Chantal move has
acknowledged the risk that to bring
together Democratic demands in the
creation of a people will produce or
worse presume a homogeneous subject one
that negates plurality
however as do we sometimes did and as
I've done here move argues that the
Democratic projects must be congruent
with the values and identities of those
they seek to join in support of common
causes they must start from where people
are and how they feel offering them in
her words a vision of the future that
gives them hope at the current
historical juncture move contends this
often means beginning at the national
level and mobilizing people around a
patriotic identity
with the best and most egalitarian
aspects of the national tradition she
does not go so far as to argue that we
must develop better stories of people
hood or to analyze how this might be
done but her arguments point in this
direction move stops short
however precisely because she wants
notions of the people to be constructed
around democracy with democratic values
in the leading role in defining
political identities everywhere not
distinctive accounts of particular
people hood this is an endeavor worth
pursuing still there are several reasons
to doubt whether devotion to democracy
as the central goal of political life
can provide a sufficient sense of common
purpose to play the mobilizing rule
asked of it in this regard sociologist
Ruth Browns Dean's 2017 book prophets
and Patriots faith and democracy across
the political divide is instructive
Brownstein engaged in extensive
ethnographic observations and
discussions beginning in 2010 with
members of a liberal religious activist
group called interfaith and a
conservative Tea Party group called the
Patriots Brownstein found that though
these groups differed sharply on many
issues and though they organized in
different ways they shared both some
common grievances and some common ideals
they embraced a quote similar ideal of
good citizenship understanding it to
mean active engagement in furthering
what they saw as the American democratic
project in this Brownstein very
reasonably found some hope she argued
much as I have done that as long as
multiple groups cultivate and enact
different stories of America and no
single story becomes dominant their
commitments to democratic engagement
might lead them to search for sufficient
common ground and to accept enough
compromises to hold the nation together
and even enable it to progress
Brownstein also noted however that
despite their overlapping senses of
commitment to the project of American
democracy her two groups had fundamental
disagreements on a number of issues that
appeared nearly impossible to resolve it
is not clear
whether even the strong and shared sense
of these groups that they are dedicated
to advancing democracy can foster enough
willingness to a comedy comedy to each
other to enable them to work together
constructively the very fact that Browns
teens prophets and Patriots are
activists moreover probably indicates
that they are more drawn to democratic
engagement than most Americans are it's
true that Civic Republican and more
modern democratic traditions valorising
active public service constitute
significant features of American
political culture even so it's likely
that most Americans see Democratic
activism the way that Oscar Wilde
famously described socialism it takes up
too many of one's evenings there are
also other challenges facing efforts to
motivate and inclusive egalitarian
politics through appeals to democracy
alone as the history of the United
States and many other countries shows
that democracy means unqualified
majoritarian rule the rights of many
minorities especially ethno-cultural
minorities are not likely to be safe and
as James Madison warned and as Francis
Rosen Bluth and Ian Shapiro have
recently affirmed many institutions such
as the selection of Representatives can
be excessively or at least poorly
democratized making it necessary to save
democracy from itself in their phrase or
to find a Republican remedy for the
disease's most incident to Republican
government in Madison's phrase perhaps
most disturbingly less than half of
young Americans today say they take an
active interest in politics and they are
less inclined to affirm democracy as
always the best form of government than
older Americans are so there's serious
obstacles to seeking to make democratic
values the central theme of American
political life though to be sure all
conceivable options face obstacles still
these considerations suggest that in
addition to stories of Americans as a
people engaged in democratic
self-governance other desirable stories
of American people who may be needed in
the quest to spur movements that can
defeat pathological forms of populism so
next
the e pluribus unum story the preamble
to the Constitution summarizes the
purposes that we the people of the
United States gave their federal
government and the first goal is to form
a more perfect union soon thereafter in
1789 Congress adopted the Great Seal of
the United States with a design that
included the motto he pluribus unum out
of many one since the nation's founding
it has always been possible to narrate
the American people as devoted to
forming a greater unity out of their
manifold diversity yet no American
political leader leader has ever
identified the American story and his
own story so fully with that goal as
Barack Obama did beginning with the
speech at the 2004 Democratic convention
that catapulted him to prominence there
Obama expressed gratitude for the
diversity of my heritage and he stressed
that his biography was quote part of the
larger American story in ways that made
him indebted to America since in no
other country on earth he said could his
story be even possible Obama traced that
possibility back to America's commitment
to the proposition in the Declaration of
Independence that all are created equal
Obama did not however contend that the
American project was simply or chiefly
to secure equal rights for all
instead he maintained using biblical and
familial language that alongside our
famous individualism there's another
ingredient in the American saga a belief
that we're all connected as one people I
am my brother's keeper I am My Sister's
Keeper it's what allows us to pursue our
individual dreams and yet still come
together as one American family
eeep Laura bassoon 'm out of many one
the larger story of america that obama
portrayed then was one that appealed to
the Declaration of Independence but
interpreted it in light of the nation's
religious traditions of moral obligation
and civic Republican conceptions of
civic virtues and duties in his 2000
speech announcing his candidacy for the
presidency Obama said his campaign was
about reclaiming the meaning of
citizenship restoring our sense of
common purpose when his campaign faced a
crisis due to inflammatory remarks
as pastor Reverend Jeremiah Wright Obama
responded with a speech at the National
Constitution Center in Philadelphia that
began by interpreting the Constitution
as stained by this nation's original sin
of slavery but with the answer to the
slavery question Obama contended already
embedded in it describing that answer
Obama said the Constitution had at it's
very core the ideal of equal citizenship
under the law and promised its people
liberty injustice and a union that could
be and should be perfected over time to
continue in that quest Obama asserted
Americans needed to see that we may have
different stories but we hold common
hopes we all want to move in the same
direction defined by the idea that out
of many we are truly one in a speech at
Cairo later in 2009 Obama restated his
claim that America was shaped by every
culture drawn from every end of the
earth and dedicated to a simple concept
he pluribus unum out of many one
he then affirmed that the same was a
cosmopolitan one asserting that globally
as well as domestically all people have
a responsibility to one enough to one
another as human beings to work together
for common benefit speaking again to his
fellow Americans in his 2012 nomination
acceptance speech Obama maintained that
the nation's founding beliefs and
inalienable rights fostered commitments
to personal responsibility and
individual initiative but also does
citizenship the idea that this country
only works when we accept certain
obligations to one another into future
generations and it is eloquent second
inaugural Obama called the declaration
self-evident truths of human equality
and inalienable rights what makes us
Americans while insisting that
preserving our individual freedoms
ultimately requires collective action as
one nation and one people as citizens
Obama's remarkable success in becoming
the nation's first African American
president and then a two-term president
proves that this e pluribus unum story
especially in his telling had undeniable
resonance it promised respect for all in
ways that would give recognition to many
forms of diversity
it thus complies with the three hours of
good stories of people hood that I've
laid out the experience of Obama's
presidency however raises cautionary
concerns one that Obama himself came to
express I've argued that Obama conceived
of the American quest of EEP Laura
bassoon um as best pursued in the spirit
of John Dewey's democratic pragmatism
and modern theories of deliberative
democracy even as Obama stressed that
most forms of diversity need not and
should not be suppressed in efforts to
achieve a more perfect union his
openness to whatever solutions pragmatic
deliberative democratic process
processes produced meant that his vision
of Union could appear devoid of any
specific content and therefore somewhat
hollow still more importantly when
Republicans in Congress refused to
engage in good faith democratic
deliberations and negotiations Obama's
Laura bus Unum conception of the
American project gave him no real
guidance as to how to respond his best
hope was simply to defeat his
intransigent opponents at the polls
while Obama remained popular however he
did not find a way to sustain much less
expand the broad base of support for his
party he built in 2008 during his
reelection campaign in 2012 Obama said
that the mistake of my first term was
thinking that this job was just about
getting the policy right the nature of
this office is to tell a story to the
American people that gives them a sense
of unity and purpose and optimism
especially during tough times the second
inaugural address told is e pluribus
unum story as well as he or perhaps
anyone else has ever done but it did not
alter the reality of a nation that was
growing more polarized not more United
his foreign policy advisor and
speechwriter Ben Rhodes has written that
late in a second term Obama read Yuval
Harare sapiens and was reinforced in the
belief that his job was to quote tell a
really good story about who we are at
Hiroshima in May 2016 Obama reflected
the nation's quote arise
telling a story that binds people
together and sacrifice and cooperation
but those same stories have so often
been used to oppress and dehumanize
those who are different he said my own
Nation story began with simple words all
men are created equal and endowed by our
creator with certain unalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
realizing that ideal has never been easy
but staying true to that story is worth
the effort
this time however Obama did not
explicitly identify the American story
with the quest to achieve a pluralist
unum though he did insist that the
radical and necessary notion that we are
part of a single human family that is
the story that we all must tell he
seemed to acknowledge tacitly that
American people hood should perhaps be
narrated somewhat differently than he
had done during the preceding dozen
years if Obama had indeed reached that
conclusion I will next argue that he was
correct when Obama said at Hiroshima as
he had said previously that his nation's
story began with the words of the
Declaration of Independence he was
advancing a debatable and long debated
view following the example of many
Antebellum Protestant Whigs Ronald
Reagan usually identified the nation's
origins with John Winthrop speech to the
Puritans when winter promised that they
would be as a city upon a hill scholars
had often noted that the adoption of the
Constitution rather than the declaration
is the origin of America's national
government and courts as well as critics
of the declaration if often insisted
that this second founding is the truly
authoritative one the most influential
expression of the view that America
instead began with the Declaration of
Independence is Lincoln's Gettysburg
Address in 1863 and its famous opening
four score and seven years ago our
fathers brought forth upon this
continent a new nation conceived in
Liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal if we do
the math and recognize the last five
words we know he's referring to 1770
six in the Declaration of Independence
Lincoln did not arrive at this view of
nation starting point in 1863 nor did he
originate it Lincoln also did not
interpret its implications precisely as
Barack Obama would do as a mandate to
pursue a pluribus unum greater unity
without a facing diversity instead
Lincoln spoke in a broad American
tradition of invoking the declaration in
order to claim that more people should
have their basic rights better secured
that tradition already included
Jacksonian working men's advocates and
the antebellum women's rights movement
and it has gone on through the course of
US history to include champions of
property rights but also human rights
civil rights held G btq rights
disability rights and other rights up to
the present day Lincoln spoke
particularly in the tradition of though
not in full agreement with the advocates
of anti-slavery constitutionalism
including the Massachusetts abolitionist
Lysander Spooner and the editor and
former slave Frederick Douglass in 1845
Spooner published the
unconstitutionality of slavery arguing
that the people of this country first
announced their independent political
existence and in a document that
amounted to constitutional law and that
took as a self-evident truth the
principle that all men had a natural
right to Liberty making slavery
unconstitutional a position Spooner
insisted the 1787 Constitution did not
disavow Frederick Douglass building on
Spooner came after his break with the
garrison and abolitionists to argue
citing the Supreme Court that in reading
legal documents the language of the law
must be construed strictly in favor of
justice and Liberty since the
Constitution did not use the word
slavery and instead promised like the
Declaration to secure the blessings of
liberty Douglass maintained Americans
could and should read it as an
anti-slavery document Lincoln did not
agree that the Constitution by itself
banned slavery still he and the new
Republican Party came to adopt a
moderate version of anti-slavery
constitutionalism in the
1850s and 1860s they contended that the
Constitution had been intended and
should be administered to pursue the
fulfillment of the principles of the
Declaration by putting slavery on the
path to preferably peaceful gradual but
ultimately complete extinction in
speeches of the 1850s Lincoln often
called the declarations proclamation of
human equality and inalienable rights a
maxim set up for future use it should be
he said constantly looked to constantly
labored for and even though never
perfectly attained constantly
approximated and so constantly spreading
and deepening its influence thereby
augmenting the happiness and value of
life to all people of all colors
everywhere
Lincoln's embrace of this view propelled
him through more personal growth on
racial issues than many modern critics
appreciate though he had earlier urged
only that African Americans deserved
equality in regard to the basic rights
of the Declaration of Independence not
full political equality Lincoln
eventually concluded that if African
Americans were to gain meaningful
possession of even those basic rights
many of them would need the franchise
his announcement of that position
spurred his assassination by John Wilkes
Booth Lincoln's evolution on the
question of african-american voting
rights highlights a fundamental
difference between his understanding of
American people who it is a project to
fulfilling the principles of the
Declaration of Independence and Barack
Obama's for Obama the goal was fostering
unity through processes of deliberative
democracy if unity did not emerge it was
not clear what to do for Lincoln the
goal was more specific and less
conciliatory it was the extension of
basic rights to all a project that
policies must advance and a project that
could justify overriding sometimes by
force the preferences of those who would
deny rights to some Lincoln's conception
of American people hood stands in far
more striking contrast however to
Trump's america-first vision to be sure
Lincoln casts this declaration of
independence
I request more as a means to make
America a shining example to the world
then an effort to justify any expansive
American rule beyond our borders
Lincoln's focus was on holding the
nation together yet despite this
similarity to trump when Lincoln said
the nation should labor to spread the
influence of the Declaration of
Independence to augment the happiness
and value of life for all people he
meant all people there were no other
people who didn't matter at the height
of the popularity of the
anti-immigration know-nothings in the
1850s Lincoln wrote his friend Joshua's
speed I am NOT a know-nothing
that is certain how could I be how could
anyone who abhors the oppression of
Negroes be in favor of degrading classes
of white people our progress and
degeneracy appears to me to be pretty
rapid as a nation we began by declaring
that all men are created equal
we now practically read it all men are
created equal except Negroes when the
know-nothings get controlled it will
read all men are created equal except
Negroes and foreigners and Catholics
today I think Lincoln would add and
Muslims though lincoln was first and
foremost concerned about his fellow
citizens it is clear that he thought
that if any policies worked against the
goal of securing the enjoyment of
declaration of independence rights for
all people everywhere those policies
violated the values to which the
American people were and should be
dedicated and whether or not Lincoln in
the Republicans were right to see the
original Constitution as dedicated to
the declaration of independence project
of securing rights for all they wrote
their vision into the Constitution in
the form of the three great Civil War
amendments it can now even more clearly
claim constitutional authority even
prior to that throughout US history and
indeed throughout the world so many
diverse movements have chosen to invoke
the principles of the Declaration that
its story like Democratic stories has
great claim to be a major historical
asset for inclusive egalitarian reforms
even though wealthy have also used it to
buttress their economic privileges part
of its resonance comes from its support
for a great
variety of pursuits of happiness not any
single vision of human fulfillment
consequently I believe this sense of
American identity as distinctively
dedicated to the Declaration of
Independence project of expanding the
enjoyment of basic rights provides a
more broadly appealing and sustaining
sense of purpose than either Democratic
stories or Obama's ether bassoons story
still too many years this narrative of
American identity sounds several alarms
it may lead Americans to be obsessed
with claiming rights for themselves as
individuals instead of pursuing common
goods or Americans may rest satisfied
with a formal equality of rights that
belies the fact that many live in
conditions of crippling material
inequalities worst of all more
privileged Americans may use claims to
be protecting rights to impose their own
self-interested conceptions of how
others should live on diverse
communities at home and abroad these
concerns have force they suggest
Americans must significantly expand upon
the Civil War Republicans understanding
of what securing meaningful rights for
all entails as the intertwined history
of modern labor and civil rights
struggles has long since affirmed
policies and practices must help people
acquire the economic educational and
political resources and capabilities
they need to exercise their rights today
in the United States as elsewhere it is
vital to address the needs and concerns
of both the deeply disadvantaged and
those constituencies who though better
off still feel economically and
culturally endangered by globalizing
trends Americans disagree sharply about
how to do so particularly in regards to
redistributed measures public
investments and direct public provision
of services Lincoln favored among other
things state investment in public roads
and highways public schools charities
and orphanages as well as the
administration of criminal and civil
justice systems along with all other
things that the people in his words
cannot do it all or cannot so well do
for themselves
Lincoln's list goes too far for
some today still most Americans appear
willing to support some forms of
national aid to communities and workers
that lose jobs due to economic
globalization or necessary environmental
regulations many now recognize that the
benefits of immigration tend to be
national
but the burdens are often locally
concentrated making assistance programs
for regions facing demands for expanded
social services from very recent
immigrants appropriate trade agreements
that include better pay for workers and
immigrants sending regions are part of
the answer to both economic and cultural
concerns and to his credit Trump has
sought them a still greater opportunity
in this regard however is the America
first promised Trump has neglected
public infrastructure spending on
construction of transportation
communications energy production water
supply and educational facilities with
environmental protections these
investments could generate employment
for displaced native workers who
supported Trump and for the immigrants
he is assailed while spurring sustained
economic growth for many decades as
Lincoln came to recognize in regard to
the nation's african-american citizens
it's also a continuing task for
Americans to improve their democratic
institutions certainly by removing
instead of imposing barriers to
participation
perhaps by altering candidate selection
processes to reduce the influence of
extremist activists most important now
is to find ways to restructure the rules
and practices of Congress to restore it
to its past role as the centerpiece of
representative governance before
heightened electoral preoccupations and
polarization let it to abandon authority
to the other branches it is moreover
simply true that powerful groups have
often prompted American governments to
pursue their interests by imposing their
preferred ways of life their preferred
forms of economic activities and
cultural pursuits on many minorities at
home and on other political societies
abroad these practices violate the
Declaration of Independence projects for
its rights include the pursuit of
happiness and people's notions of
happiness legitimately vary as do the
social economic and
barriers they face to be effective
policies seeking to enable all to enjoy
their basic rights securely therefore
must be not just resonant and respectful
but also what I'm calling reticulated
policies by which I mean they cannot
treat all persons in strictly uniform
fashion Americans must engage in
continuing changing contextual judgments
about what forms of affirmatively
accommodating treatment of groups and
identities will augment the happiness
and value of life for all concerned and
what forms of differential treatment
will instead foster divisions
inequalities and in justices those
judgments are difficult but they are
unavoidable if Americans are to respect
legitimate differences in ways that
build on the best aspects of our common
heritage to engage in a shared
enterprise that benefits all for
Americans to make these policy judgments
well I have argued that we need to
develop a new civic ethos we must
encourage all to pursue amongst the
diverse forms of happiness they may seek
individually and as communities those
that are most valuable to others as well
as to themselves in part because those
choices do most to permit and sometimes
assist others in pursuing their
distinctive forms of happiness many
modern societies professing liberal
democratic principles have defined the
justice they seek to establish in terms
of the harm principle of John Stuart
Mill which contended the only purpose
for which power can be rightfully
exercised over any member of a civilized
community against his will is to prevent
harm to others modern millions often
wisely fear that these harms will be
defined in terms of the ethnocentric
definitions of civilized communities
that Mill himself often endorsed
consequently they adapt Mills harm
principle along lines like those of the
19th century American philosopher and
anti-slavery advocate Ralph Waldo
Emerson today it's more customary to
suggest that each person is entitled to
the maximum amount of self defined
freedom and self-realization possible
consistent with the self defined freedom
and self realization of others rather
than invoking the standard
of civilized communities this turn to
protection of self defined freedoms
however raises a great danger persons
pursuing pleura pluralistic forms of
self-realization may well clash far more
than they cooperate but recall that
today even more than in the past most
people recognize themselves as complex
beings with many affiliations identities
and aspirations and so many so multiple
possible identities that awareness can
feel I've suggested as if we're hearing
a cacophony of stories of our possible
people hood making simple narrow
nationalist appeals India first America
first attractive yet that same awareness
may inspire us to embrace more
reticulated forms of policy in public
life within our society and across
societies it might enable us to see that
we can seek satisfying forms of
self-realization in many different ways
ways that while they would provide
roughly equal satisfaction for us might
have better or worse consequences for
others and then to show respect for
those others we must take those
consequences seriously in the choices we
make
I've therefore suggested that in pursuit
of their Declaration of Independence
project Americans should adopt a
modified million Maxim as both a
personal and Seva civic ethos that
modified Maxim is the best uses of their
powers by communities and individuals
are those that aid others without doing
harm to themselves both to meet our own
needs and goals and to do right by our
fellow citizens in the 21st century we
need to go beyond focusing on harm
prevention to be sure efforts to combat
harms including disabling forms of
discrimination subordination and
material harder hardship must remain
central and those efforts will remain
difficult with clashes over what
constitutes harm and who is responsible
for harms yet it still makes sense to
strive more consciously to exercise our
rights individually and as a nation in
ways that been a
that others not just ourselves doing so
means at times we should favor giving
accommodations and exemptions in public
policies to some individuals and groups
because doing so will not do harm to
ourselves and it will enable others to
pursue happiness as they define it more
successfully and in ways more
practically equal to our own
opportunities instead of simply live and
let live we need a civic ethos of live
and help live aided by this ethos the
American Declaration of Independence
project can become not only resonant and
respectful but one that provides guides
for more appropriately reticulated
policies and practices than it has
fostered in the nation's past
legislators and executives devising
public policies in courts adjudicating
them should apply this modified Maxim
when responding to the claims of a wide
range of advocates for special
exemptions and accommodations including
religious groups linguistic cultural
ethnic and racial minorities the poor
the disabled women LGBTQ persons and
groups children the elderly and more
rather than regarding all special
treatment as suspect as is often the
case now American lawmakers and courts
should reverse the burden of proof they
should only reject the claims of groups
- affirmative accommodations when those
denials are necessary to achieve
compelling governmental purposes
purposes which must be more than simple
hostility to the groups in question or
simply a concern that they give the
nation total allegiance to be truly
inclusive and respectful toward all
moreover those efforts at accommodation
must include conservative religious
groups as well as displaced workers new
immigrants long disadvantaged minorities
and more for many probably many here
this may be the implication of the
declaration of independence project
that's most difficult to accept there
are many good reasons to worry that this
call for extensive accommodations will
only heighten fragmentation and
inequality not promote an egalitarian
inclusive sense of common endeavor
in assessing the force of this very
appropriate concern one fundamental
safeguard should be borne in mind if we
believe in equal rights if we accept
that each group and individual should
have rights that have comparable value
but not greater value than those granted
to other groups and individuals then we
may frequently find the denials of
demands for special rights and
accommodations are justified by
compelling state interests once
governments provide accommodations to
any one group they must provide them to
all groups who similarly claim those
accommodations are vital to their
pursuits of happiness this means that
both legislators and courts must ask
what the consequences will be of
granting for example exemptions from the
Affordable Care Act requirements not
only to conservative religious groups
and to corporations owned by small
groups of religious believers but to all
entities who make similar demands a
position the Trump administration has
endorsed if there are many other such
bodies than the accommodations in total
may be too costly both in dollars and in
terms of their impacts on other public
pools to be acceptable similarly if we
repeal the 1954 Johnson amendment to the
tax code and permit religious groups to
endorse political candidates as
president Trump has moved to do we must
allow all tax-exempt advocacy groups to
endorse candidates we cannot grant
religious traditionalists full political
speech rights and tax exemptions while
denying one or the other
two environmental and animal rights
advocacy groups it's not clear the Trump
administration would support granting
full political speech rights to
tax-exempt organizations under these
circumstances finally if the refusal of
fundamentalist religious cake designers
to serve same-sex couples means that
those couples will have few
opportunities to purchase desirable
cakes or that they will face related
kinds of material burdens than
exemptions from general policies of
non-discrimination when serving the
public would be illegitimate
if however requests for accommodations
really are confined to a small number of
groups businesses and individuals while
the interests of those adversely
affected by those accommodations can be
met through
costless alternative policies than it is
wise and just to support those
accommodations I include those
conservative cake Baker's so long as
they publicly advertise their policies
lessening occasions for embarrassing
confrontations and painful
confrontations and also I think costing
them a great deal of business now it's
true that those denied service may well
feel their dignity and identities have
been disrespected but it's also true
that those compelled to provide service
equally feel their dignity and
identities have been disrespected so
long as same-sex couples can receive
respectful service from most other
providers a civic ethos of accommodation
whenever possible calls for permitting
religious bakers an exemption in some we
should take seriously the claims for
accommodations advanced by long
discriminated against or neglected
communities and those put forth by
groups experiencing new economic
anxieties due to economic globalization
environmental regulations technological
innovations and unresponsive public
policies and the claims of traditional
religious and cultural communities whose
feelings of threatened status led them
to embrace Trump's vision if
accommodations and exemptions do not go
so far as to permit some to burden what
modern Americans define as basic civil
rights and compelling public purposes
these accommodations may well contribute
to civic peace and heightened civic
engagement
improving the prospects for many to
pursue happiness in fulfilling ways
perhaps paradoxically but beneficially
the incredibly rich diversity of modern
America makes it likely that many
requests for distinctive privileges will
be advanced by so few groups that they
can be granted these policies would
moreover promote the flourishing of a
wide variety of diverse civil
associations of the sort that many have
long thought to be America's best
schools for citizenship such
associations can help foster the sort of
civic ethos that Americans need they are
often great venues for developing habits
and practices of working cooperatively
with others for the pursuit not just of
individuals self-interest but also of
common goods through those pursuit
a wide range of economic and cultural
communities from Midwestern farmers to
public sector labor organizers to
immigrant advocacy groups to
fundamentalist Christians to militantly
proud to have culture groups to persons
of mixed race to send to families with
transgender members may all come to feel
that they are truly part of the larger
American political project they might
then work together to realize a vision
of America as a pluralist but unified
nation that strives seriously and
persistently to make meaningful
enjoyment of the basic declaration of
independence rights possible for all
these are the reasons why I find a civic
narrative of America as a people
dedicated to realizing the principles of
the Declaration of Independence for all
over time a far more compelling and
promising vision than Trump's America
first story or even the Democratic
stories of figures like Dewey or the e
pluribus unum story of Obama but as its
invocation on behalf of many very
different positions throughout US
history indicates this Declaration of
Independence narrative provides no
certain guides for dressing all the
problems that beset modern America it
also has limitations that may well lead
many Americans to prefer a different
account of their identities and purposes
as stated at the outset even though I
favor this story my goal is not to argue
that this is the single conception of
American civic identity to which all
should give allegiance much less total
allegiance as the writer Chimamanda
Ngozi Adichie has said in a widely
viewed TED talk the danger of a single
story is that it can rob people of
dignity by making of our making our
recognition of our equal humanity with
full awareness of our differences
difficult consequently I hope instead to
encourage others to identify and advance
the better stories of people hood that
most appeal to them then we can look for
areas of overlap the issues where we can
find common ground for resistance to and
justices and common paths for progress
it is not by all coming to adopt any one
story of people hood but rather through
many people advancing different stories
all saying that xenophobia racism
misogyny and religion
bigotry are not who we are now as
Americans that the United States can
become not only more United but the best
that we can hope to make it we must look
for many stories that resonate that are
respectful and that are reticulated
stories that provide secure places for
as many diverse groups as possible in
the networks that comprise our society
and in the larger regional and global
networks to which we can productively
belong by doing so we may find that our
stories have many harmonies and that we
can collectively build bridges across
our divides if we build well they will
be bridges on which we all can stand and
bridges from which we can all look out
with new hope toward the future whose
story we all will write perhaps we can
write and tell and live better stories
of people hood than all those that have
gone before
[Applause]
well I was if a divorce rises and in
keeping with the traditions of EPA we
will ask for questions from students
first I one of the narratives that was
in the back of my mind too is especially
we you've brought the example of Barack
Obama and positioning Obama not only as
you know an interlocutor of this larger
American Studies story but also the
larger African American story right
right he's putting forth a bishop the
place of African Americans within
America is very much in love with MLK
it's I'd even before the but you know
there are I think movements like black
lives matter what they know but for this
where is reckoning in the story of
America right i Newman WB Dubois writes
about it in black reconstruction writing
saying that a lot of what this civic
Republicans did was actually
acknowledged with the you know America's
nation that this wrong now let's try to
fix it the problem is the long night of
Kim after of life there the
Reconstruction period right which
doesn't fare well for now hopes this in
the part of it but do you think there's
a chance for that reckoning right for an
acknowledgement during the way the
cannabis ring doing right now towards
indigenous peoples and the way that a
lot of African nations happen to in the
aftermath of decolonization I think
there's a potential and also a danger if
the presentation of the need for
reckoning is presented primarily as a
message that white Americans at least
need to feel deep shame even though I
think that's justified in many respects
it is likely to be a politically
counterproductive
message if the reckoning is presented as
part of a story of yes these are
failings and here's how we can do better
if it is if you don't focus on the shame
but as the from the opportunity for
improvement then you can have the
reckoning and use it as a source of
mobilisation and in this regard in
relation to Barack Obama I think one of
the mistakes that he made although it's
understandable is that he steered away
from identifying himself too strongly
with the black church social justice
tradition which I believe he genuinely
identified with and he did invoke it on
occasion and you know very beautifully
in his Charleston eulogy and on other
occasions but I think he was worried
that if he identified himself too
strongly with the black Church role in
civil rights struggles he would be
perceived as only caring about black
Americans and he would lose support but
I think in fact that kind of sense of
moral purpose for many religious purpose
is something that resonated with many
Americans beyond black Americans and it
could be a useful way of saying that yes
we've done things that are sources of
shame but this is part of a project of
human improvement and the religious
narrative naturally lends itself to this
story of failing but trying to do better
and he might have been able to encourage
some sense of reckoning while motivating
a sense of purposeful progress but he
felt he couldn't do it too much because
he felt it would mark him too much as a
black president and not everybody's
president he's a better politician than
I am so maybe he was right but I still
think there may have been a lost
opportunity there
I have a question about the four
narratives how much how much are they
aspirational versus formational or
identity once especially right because
they claim give me the pony
if this is what makes the people
American people into the people in other
words is this what I do to identify
person American it was not then the
ponies at some of this stronger versions
like the one of you have to be thinking
of others isn't healthy what happens if
there is a member that all of us
recognize like we might think of them as
Americans but they fail in this category
then I point to you we have to remove
them from the people and I think that's
problematic but but independently from
that I think there's a second problem
which is as a member of the people you
can turn to them and say like look we
have these aspirations we have this
aspiration to be like non-discriminatory
and since you're part of us then usual
should change your point of view to have
the same aspirations because you're a
member of the people right if you if you
make the desperations into what makes
the people into people they start moving
people and then you cannot return to
them and tell them hey I know you're a
racist but you shouldn't do that because
you're not a good American and shelter
to be black you just tell me I'm not an
American I failed your test so I think
if we put a brain and looked at she is
definition considered definition like
the Louie okay one seems to be just what
makes America it's actually a generous
one right if your mom to America the
total allegiance is crazy but their
loyalty money the second line the
loyalty one if if America is a country
that you're going on
independent of your beliefs that actual
allows for people who are born in
another country who lives here all their
life by they loyalty come in there's
essentially relatively generous if it's
not desperation it's just constructive
well I'd say that where I disagree with
you is that I don't interpret and the
Civic ethos as a standard for deciding
who gets to be part of the people it is
it is an aspirational morality and we
might use it to judge who's a better
citizen and who's a worse citizen but
not who is a citizen and I'd also want
to stress that one of the advantages of
the Declaration of Independence
understanding is that it embraces the
notion that there are diverse pursuits
of happiness so the fact that your
happiness isn't necessarily fulfilled by
following this Maxim doesn't make you
not a member of the political community
so this isn't a test for membership it
is rather a kind of ethos designed if a
lot of people embrace it to make
membership work better but the it's an
ethos nonetheless that accepts the
legitimacy of pluralism and difference
and therefore is not a basis for
expelling someone from the community
whereas I think if you say you have to
give total allegiance to the United
States then there are many many
identities and aspirations that are
suppressed by that I don't want to give
total allegiance to the United States
and we're not psychology
[Music]
these subcultures you know they give up
what they should be what they are and
they're all just sort of next to each
other but they're not mixing or to give
up who you are and so my word is as
extensive accommodation it's not a
simulation but I don't my emphasis is
that we need to learn to be more
comfortable with what is a reality we
have multiple identities and memberships
and it should not be a choice between
simply embracing one at the expense of
the suppression of others our task is to
find ways to accommodate the peaceful
and flexible pursuit of lives in
multiple communities and memberships and
so that means that a strongly
assimilationist ideology is hostile to
what I'm talking about it is true that
you know in the first lecture I talked
about how the fragmentation in modern
life can create so many claims on us
that people experience themselves
is hearing a cacophony of stories about
who they are and who they should be and
that creates difficulties in way I'm
trying to encourage an ethos that makes
us a little more comfortable living with
the fact that we will be a member of a
subgroup and a member of an American
nation and a member of transnational
communities all at once I think it's in
some respects you can say it's
psychologically hard to do and yet the
reality is that we do it to some degree
all the time now and we just need to I
think begin to develop an understanding
that really that's the way it should be
Trump's to write such chase
so in incorporating write some pretty an
important piece of this project to what
extent does America need to go through
kind of a rehabilitation of the
political concept
well I'm sympathetic to that argument I
haven't put it rights as chips I have
put it that rights are tools not Trump's
rights are really a kind of legal and
policy device for helping structure
things to accomplish our purposes and we
should not treat them as absolutes
because no tool works forever or for
every situation but at the same time it
is often useful to construct policies
and institutions with rights as means to
accomplish our goals and so I think we
do need an acceptance of rights as tools
I acknowledge that this is in some
tension with the original understanding
of the Declaration of Independence as
inalienable rights older natural rights
doctrines and in this sense I do want to
say that the modern version of the
doctrine does refound its goal
on more pragmatist foundations to a
large degree but does maintain true to
the same basic goals
to be aware of in the case of the
conservative bakers what is there to
guarantee that that situation is the
case where a client or customer would
have other options available I think
that you look at the actual empirical
reality of the situation in the context
where the case arises and if things
change over time you change the policy
and the reality is that in the
masterpiece cake incident they said it
was not a problem to purchase a cake
we could have gotten a cake dozens of
other places we just felt offended
because we weren't served and I
understand that I find a defense if they
weren't served but on the other hand the
Baker felt offended that his religious
views were not being respected by public
policy what do you do with that conflict
I think you have to look at who's really
getting hurt and if they can get I think
it's fair to require them to advertise
you know we don't serve same-sex couples
because then you don't go in and have a
confrontation that's painful and I also
think that in 21st century America right
now that would cost them business and so
I think you could drive out that kind of
discrimination but if it worked out
differently if it worked out that there
were pervasive patterns of not serving
as was true in the days of Jim Crow then
you have to ban that because then you
are really depriving people of
opportunities in the marketplace but if
you're not really depriving people of
opportunities in the marketplace and the
conservative religious Baker feels less
alienated denounced trampled upon I
think we should try to do it
say you know we value diverse ways of
diverse pursuits of happiness you know I
don't agree with yours but you're not
hurting other people in any way you
don't the government can't get in the
business of deciding whether something
is a genuine or religious belief or not
doing so is something the government's
not competent to do in its decisions
amount to the a government effort to
establish religion because it's deciding
what's religion and what isn't so one of
the risks of the approach is yes you're
open to people making all kinds of
fraudulent claims but again if lots of
people are making those claims for
whatever reasons they're saying we
aren't going to serve you then you say
well this is a major impediment on these
peoples opportunities to participate in
the market and we can't allow that how
you think about the subtracted the
ability of our like the wise in this
person goes meaning I think you kind of
reference those who philosophy and we
articulating it from lips and
live-and-let-live sort of living health
live but what happens when my inclusion
into of public good diminishes you're a
piece of the pie too you know because
then it isn't that adding you is
hurt me it's that adding you reduces my
ability to live as happily as or as
happily as I previously what's this it
does although what you are saying could
be played out in several different ways
it might be that we've got a set of
material resources and if you get some
there's less for me it might be that I
feel your inclusion lessens my status
somehow even if not my material
resources and it may be that I just feel
an aversion to having you on the same
level as same space as me even if it's
not a question of loss of status per se
there are going to be clashing
conceptions of pursuits of happiness and
if people can only be made happy by
denying pretty fundamental rights to
other people then they lose this is
again the example of the the teeth in
the Lincoln vision that the mission is
to secure basic rights as broadly as
possible and if my happiness is just
bound up by denying you basic rights
that doesn't count
that's not a permissible pursuit of
happiness because the mission is to
provide basic rights for all and so yeah
I do feel that my in that case my
pursuit of happiness is being thwarted
but this is a case where there's a clash
that as you've defied it you might not
be able to resolve if you can find a
win-win solution of its material
resources and we can both get more
material resources and we're both happy
fine that's what we should always do but
if it is true that my happiness depends
on your
happiness then the declaration of
independent projects as I have defined
it and especially with this modified
ethos that doesn't count
well one thing to do is you know the
modern Congress has adopted policies
where they're really only in Washington
three days a week because they in
session three days a week because and
then they run back home and they raise
money and they campaign so they don't
spend a lot of time together working on
the public's problems and trying to find
common ground solutions you could change
the rules to restrict time away from
Washington and also keep them in session
more and you know if they had to stay
together and work on problems they might
do a little better might not but that's
one change and Josh Chaffetz has a book
on Congress that has a number of reforms
a law professor at Cornell who was a
Yale undergraduate back in the day well
that's where these two have been writing
about it is true that we have a primary
process now in which we tend to select
more ideologically extreme candidates
because those who are active in
primaries and are more likely primary
voters tend to be both more politically
knowledgeable and engaged but also more
extreme and in the past we relied less
heavily on primaries to choose
candidates and did allow party officials
more of a role in selecting candidates
it is even though primaries began in the
Progressive Era they didn't become the
pre
pattern in American candidate selection
until the last third of the 20th century
and you know for instance Ted white
wrote the book making the president 1960
about Kennedy campaigning in primaries
but he campaigned in primaries in
something like less than a third of the
states because those were the only
primaries they were and and that was a
novelty then Kennedy campaigned in the
primaries only because people thought he
couldn't be elected because he was a
Catholic and he had to go out and win
the primaries to show him and his
success and Ted White's book success
contributed to adopting presidential
primaries much more extensively now so
that we you know now you have to win the
primaries but you know Hubert Humphrey
got the nomination in 1968 without
running in the primaries yeah he didn't
he wasn't a declared well Johnson was
running for a while and he was his vice
president so he wasn't going to run and
then Johnson pulled out of the race but
Humphrey didn't get involved in the
primaries he got he he may have been on
the ballot in a couple of the later
primaries but he wasn't and most of the
primaries and he got selected because
most of the delegates were party leaders
or under the control of party leaders we
may need a balance in which the parties
have more of a role in vetting
candidates to make the parties more a
team working together rather than a set
of ideologues and divas which is what we
tend to get now very appealing but I'd
like to get you to just talk a little
bit more about the the place of thinking
about power and all of this that you
know you you say well it the the
accommodation should depend on how how
many people are seeking a
kind of accommodation if it's only a few
we needn't worry and sisters of so it's
either the number or in relation to your
answers here it's a sort of like you
know lock see everyone has a right to be
part of the comment and a lot as long as
they're not excluding others from the
common but I'm wondering why you don't
go down because even some very small
minorities can be extremely powerful and
obnoxious so why don't you want to go
down the path of some sort of discrete
and insular minorities type of
constraint is it because you think it's
a bad idea or you don't think it fits
into the Lincoln story or both I think
that the definition of discrete and
insular minority is not flexible enough
to provide for all the range of
accommodations that you might need are
women a discrete and insular minority
well maybe in one sense maybe not you
can just what about the disabled or the
elderly or the young well in some sense
there are minorities but are they
discrete and insular that exact phrase
but you don't seem to want to go down
the idea powerless or dominated or
disadvantaged minorities or groups
seeking accommodation from just any
groups and I is it you you know I just
main reason for that is to promote a
sense of yeah latarian inclusion which
you inevitably lose if only certain
groups can get a hearing of a claim for
special accommodation whether it's
granted or not but if they're not even
allowed to be heard because they're a
privileged group in other respects you
promote a sense of in Galit aryan
inclusion if you take this approach and
you don't foster this sense of
resentment and grievance that is a
fire running through which is something
that you mentioned beginning the problem
of focusing too much on self-interest
so they give too many people and say oh
yeah you know this is here I kind of
respect I've heard it I feel
disrespected I had claim here and there
so how do you make sure I didn't make
you happy you did say something about
that they're not too many claims for
accommodation right but I wasn't really
convinced by by that and I see that now
playing out also in Europe specifically
in Germany where it's like you know if I
get my if I get a better pension for my
grandmother then I don't want I want to
use kind of money for that rather than
for
Fuji's coming in so of course you know
that's like then another question which
is like people or brights coming in from
outside because you know they can
response to him you said welcome the
most important things to keep them an
entire base together but they're like so
many questions right when it comes to
like what counts as what in relation to
those like rights independent rights
well one of the challenges of this
position is that it does require us to
make continuing contextual judgments
about trade-offs in our actual
circumstances and those judgments may
change as circumstances change and so
you know there may be times in which it
doesn't particularly hurt any of our
other pursuits to accept refugees or to
redistribute funds to refugees and there
may be times when it really does and we
can't achieve other compelling purposes
so the policies do shift at different
times
and there isn't a clear bright set of
guidelines as to what the right answers
are that apply across different contexts
and times there's just the same inquiry
the same questioning about whether can I
really pursue forms of satisfaction that
are fulfilling to me while also helping
others and we just the quest is to try
and give honest answers to those under
our current circumstances you may say
well that's too uncertain and in fact
there are different answers in different
places or the same places at different
times all that's very on
satisfying and it's so difficult to make
those kinds of contextual judgments but
step back a minute the way we at the
world really works is that we do make
all those judgments all the time and we
do change them over time I'm just
calling for more self conscious
reflection on what we are actually doing
so you know if you say that's too hard
what you're really saying is I want to
keep doing it without thinking about it
too much which I don't think is a better
guide forward my enduring disagreements
with Roger sustained from decades I have
maintained that he's a political
theorist my case
[Applause]
[Music]